welcome to this video a new episode of
the middlegame strategy series here the
series is about showing demonstrating
middlegame patterns and ideas the more
you see of them did the better your own
middle game will become enriching your
positional understanding and the variety
of ideas that you have in opposition
let's see what happened in this game
that we're going to look at it's played
by by a young later
World Championship Bobby Fischer from
1960 1960 meets that Fischer at the time
was 17 years old so he still very young
and um he was at the time considered to
be a big big whole big prodigy but of
course it saw years away from his run
towards the World Championship China
let's see what happened his opponent is
a local player from Argentina this was
played in Mar del Plata local player
called ganya we got an open Sicilian
night off
yeah makes us some sense that she plays
the night off um considering that night
off was living in Argentina at the time
Bishop to c4 which nowadays is
deservedly called the Fisher variation
c6 it should be 3 b5 and castles oh this
is pretty pretty standard nowadays white
often plays Queen a3 but okay at the
time this plan was not yet developed we
should be seven yeah but more common
nowadays especially 7 but the black
player is not a very well advise in in
theory as we as we seen quite quickly he
plays some knight c6 now and I think
this is not really a good setup probably
927 is better in some combination of
move order it's not quite clear to me if
nine
d7 or Bishop e7 first should be played
but it seems that this move is is not
helping him very much the reason is the
following white now captured on c6
Bishop takes or f5 by the way there are
various possibilities for black to play
b4 and trying to snatch a pawn yeah I
don't really want to show those it's
it's interesting but really does not fit
to the theme of this of this video the
technical complications after that it's
more about the rising structure f5 now
is played this is attacking this pawn on
e6 and gives some life to the bishop
won't be three this is how Fischer
usually played this opening with a quick
f4 f5 nowadays and lots of this ISM is
diffused but back then this was the
standard plan and he does this this plan
in a very very yea comfortable form as
black is not forced to play e5 now we
see the theme of this game already
taking shape the weeks gray on d5 black
has a weakness on d5 and this is some
happening quite often in various
Sicilian lines this specially called the
knight of the bullets laughs key and so
on there are many lines here we have a
situation but black must be very very
careful the reason is that white very
quickly here Queen d3 first covering fo
white quickly gets in Bishop g5 the idea
is what white wants to do he wants to
exchange his dark squared bishop against
against the night here to increase his
control over the d5 square it turns out
that the move Bishop d7 in fact wasn't
the most precise in the position if we
go back here black had the opportunity
to obtain a playable position what he
should have played as before the idea is
it's based on some concrete
consideration night
five by texty five bishop exd5
yeah I move like ETA X T five it's not
good at all because it transfers a pawn
to the d5 square where you really want
to have a piece so Bishop takes Bishop
takes Queen takes and now black has a
very concrete counter playing Queen a
six check King to h1 or will gave to
it's it's very very similar we can also
do we have to and now rook to c8 we see
that from a structural point of view
White has this favorable structure but
it does not have a minor piece left that
can occupy the d5 square the Queen now
is occupying the square and black has a
very concrete counter plate along the C
file that's very very important black
needs some compensation for structural
deficits here and white does not have
much at all it's very difficult to even
cover the pollen see tube if you
consider something like Queen d3 to
cover see to black can even play d5
initiating this threat
so maybe King f1 then there is even
Queen b5 as Jocelyn with Jack where
after this black has a combined count to
play against c2 and E form there is some
that there is something that black can
play for in this position he went which
should be seven and now Bishop g5 this
threatens what happens in the game
actually the exchange on f6 and black is
not doing much against it it's however
difficult already a move like Knight g4
for example could be considered to try
to trade Bishop for Bishop but one
problem is that after this one can just
play rook t1 and increase his pressure
on d6 black cannot reach the exchange
here which is attractive at first
because at the end he md5 hangs c6 hangs
this is a disaster
why does winning in the attack now
blacks defense is already very difficult
yeah he played the check here okay King
edge one not much choice and cathode
yeah and here we see that efficient now
can perform a very advantageous exchange
operation he takes on f6 removing the
defender of the week square that's the
typical strategy the week square he is
guarded by the noid so you take it away
here for the ducks further for the week
light square white has two pieces that
he can occupied but black only has one
to defend it the bishop on f6 is just a
spectator in destruction here white has
the the choice he can play Knight to d5
or Bishop to d5
if he goes 95 black will definitely take
him Bishop takes rook c8 maybe and let's
say c3 to remove the one from the
constant attack this position is better
for white there's no question there the
bishop on d5 is just better than the
bishop on f6
however by comparison what happened in
the game is even more problematic for
black Bishop d5 was played this move
strategically speaking is much stronger
you want to exchange the the bishop so
that you can establish a knight on d5
this is called the eternal night this
night is absolutely impossible three
means therefore this is a very
attractive move to play what needs to be
considered other concrete circumstances
in this position after rook c8 for
example white raids and black recaptures
with the rook if he would have taken
with the Queen for example we need to be
very very careful how to continue
it's all very nice but the night is not
on d5 yet here white needs to play
accurate preparation rules if you play
rook c1 for example to cover c2 so that
you can go 95 there is Bishop g5 and
suddenly things are not clear all you
have just given away control over c2 and
ya given up the pawn rook c1 does not
help but black has the idea before so
what should we do just play a
prophylactic move a3 take the active
possibility away let's say black plays
rook e8 how do you continue you want to
play 95 so what we need to do is we need
to provide some cover for the pawn rook
c1 there is again Bishop g5 does not
help but there is rook F 2 this is a
strong move
it covers c2 and allows 95 and once the
knight is there we can continue from we
can continue from there we don't really
need to establish how we continue after
that step by step improve the position
rook F 2 is a very strong maneuver in
that way black plate rook c6 so ever
yeah what should Y do now it's still
about precision if white comes Knight d5
where you want to be this isn't so great
actually black has a very strong reply
and this is quick to deform at first you
think our waiter isn't this like
absolutely terrible from a structural
point of view yes it looks like that but
it's all about concrete considerations
if white now decides check to completely
wreck a black's pawn structure black
hands to double pawns now you should
still consider concretely how to
continue in fact white has given up all
hopes of an advantage with this
operation
simply because the C pawn and the e pawn
so weak blacks somewhat wrecked
structure is not that important why Tia
has big problems to even keep the pawns
c2 is hanging immediately if you play
rock c1 black plays rook e8 and how do
you even cover you for you go rook e1
rooks e8 n c2 is falling
you cannot play this because of d3 and
black wins immediately it's a huge
mistake to play 95 that this really
would give up all the advantage fish
however of course is well known for his
precision
he played rook a to d1 this is a strong
move to prepare further proceedings it
looks at the d4 square and the black
plays Queen D form for example he could
could could do this in the next move
then there's always a queen ease to go
away from the D farm yeah black not
played rook c8 which puts up relatively
little resistance more interesting as
Queen c5 with the direct idea to play
before yeah how does white continue
after that again you need to be precise
95 is just blundering the pawn not a
good idea but we have rook T to this is
strong it covers c2 and prepares 95
again if black goes Bishop g5 we just
move the rook to e2 95 is the next idea
the figures Queen d4 we can remove the
Queen yeah and now everything is nicely
coordinated for example after f6 we
finally get in the desired 95 news with
threat of 97 and becoming C 3 will also
expel the Queen here White has Kanto to
control and will proceed from here how
we will proceed we will see in the game
this was played 95 now it's possible
because black has no active replying if
he goes Queen d4 he's unfortunately Jack
London his Queen black when Queen d8
there is no no big choice c3 was played
and now we have the perfect setup the
night is on d5
it cannot be traded against any other
minor piece and we have total control
over the position black has no active
play whatsoever
note that the c3 pawn and the knight on
d5 also control the important before
square so that a possible counter play
like a5 before is very difficult to
achieve black now went to Bishop e7 here
we come to a key position of this game
white indisputably has a very nice
position but how to continue the usual
question whitey in fact has more than
one good good way to play what I
absolutely love Fischer's continuation
here because it's so am yeah it's it's a
very original and nice solution to the
to the search of this position what
white Lexia is open files you have a
hard time to make any concrete progress
the situation is relatively closed the
knight on d5 is very nice but it also
means that with the knight on d5 you
won't win the d6 pawn easily so how can
we proceed there are two two things that
white can do white has a direct
attacking continuation and I will show
this briefly because it's not the main
point of this video white also could
have played f6 en which would have led
to a strong attack for example if black
takes white even has the strong exchange
sacrifice rook takes f6 it's quite funny
takes rook f1 and white has a very
strong attack
after King h8 for example there is Queen
to h3 which is a strong continuation
combining ideas of Knight f6 and
possibly 97 if black removes his Queen
from the guy from the e7 square for
instance Queen g8 97 is a possibility
the move f6 was strong but Fischer as it
is unknown he always wanted clarity on
the board he maybe could calculate f6 to
Amador very very forced win so he was
looking for an alternative and he came
up with a super strong strategic move
maybe you can treat this as a puzzle and
try to find how Fischer now managed to
him to make progress iam I'll be solid
for a couple of seconds and then show
the move yeah white played the very
strong move route to a 1 this is a very
very very nice move yeah it looks very
strange because it removes the rook from
the half-open default but it has a very
very clear idea quite obvious once you
see it
a4 white wants to play a form to open up
here the a file and enter with the rook
with a form he also managed to create
more weaknesses on the Queen side you
will either take on b5 and settle him
with the weak people or black needs to
take and has a weak April this is a
super strong move really like now played
played the very ugly defense f6 just to
move you don't want to play
he was probably still worried about f6
happening so f6 very very ugly effect
Bishop f8 is the move that you want to
check what happens after that yeah white
of course plays a form and here black
only has a choice between various evils
if he wants to protect the b5 pawn it
was hanging after all White has the
strongest night to be formed just
attacking the rook
picking up material for instance after
this you know the rookie has trapped you
will lose this or for example here if
black goes here you run into this fork
right before twins material if black
takes we just recapture and get a new
target after 85 white can impress the
proof look a one for example would be
eight on Queenie to something like that
the further plan is quite clear before
b5 this is how you continue here the
b-pawn is an important asset and it's
almost like have an extra pawn if you
look at this for example white enjoys
the b-pawn and the deep one is basically
yeah it's not there not anything that
black home can can use so a very very
good position for white alternatively
black here after Luke takes a form could
play rook b8 after which we go before
fixing the a6 weakness just very nice so
after a four here y term retains a great
advantage rook c4 there's a b a b b3
rook c5 rook a7 and we go from there
yeah white might even get in something
like this rook a one rook b7 rook one to
a seven black is devoid of any counter
plane unfortunately in the game in a way
unfortunately for for our purposes he
went f6 and this is really look even
more ugly
of course a4 was no played this was
officials plan all along
yeah um blacks relatively best defense
IAM is to go for something like we have
examined before but with
with the move f6 being further further
problem white now has a fantastic
position but it still would have taken
some moves to convert that yeah it's
comparable to what we've seen before
something like this you can always play
a move like that by the way yeah
make sure your king is not back rank
mate it and then go with B form
something like this ISM is a clear way
forward black is in a terrible terrible
situation the b-pawn will win the game
in the game
unfortunately the black player being
under being under that that big pressure
committed them a fatal mistake and this
led to immediate defeat unfortunately I
would have it would would be great to
see how this game would have ended in a
logical fashion in a way but what can
you do black now played rook b8 and this
is now something not very difficult
the only slight problem here for widest
that you need to consider the first move
to play it right now took only seven
Chang looks ridiculous giving up your
night against this dummy Bishop but Jan
after Queenie 725 if white just wins the
rook so black basically blundered a roll
whole rook in this game which is a shame
as mentioned it would have been great to
see the the technical phase of the game
unfold and how Fischer would have played
that would have been would have been
good to watch but still it's a very very
nice instructive example how to continue
in such a low bombing position Luke a1
is just a super strong move that shows
that you need to find good ways to open
up the position and proceed from there
white also creates further weaknesses
with this idea of a form very very very
nice way to continue yeah I hope you
enjoyed this video it's good for me yeah
seeing this this
the strong point on b5 as the starting
the starting point for further
improvements like rook a 1 and a 4 this
happens really often is to get this
eternal night and you need to proceed
from them ok I hope you liked it
thanks for watching